hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his essay the present age which is
usually read on its own but is actually
part of a
larger piece called the two ages which
was a review that
that kierkegaard wrote one of the key
aspects
of what he's calling the present age
which we might identify with our
own depending on where we are and how we
see it
is the prevalence of
envy he will in fact say that envy
becomes the negatively
unifying principle in a passionless
and very reflective age so there's a
connection between
envy which by the way is felt in other
ages we're going to talk about that in a
bit
but this this centrality of envy
and an age that is very reflective
and an age that is also essentially
passionless that doesn't mean that
nobody in the age feels passions
or anything like that but but it's we're
talking about the characteristic
of the age and the culture and the
society
and we really need to begin before
he starts talking about envy because
there's some developments
that are taking place in the work that
are leading up to why envy becomes such
an important matter
the other thing to point out too is that
envy is going to
also take the form of something that
that kierkegaard is going to call
leveling but we're not going to talk
about that quite
yet so we're going to focus on
the situation that that he he talks
about
and he tells us that we're in a
reflective
age and that there is something that he
calls
an essential or existential
rather equivocation taking place
now this is just after he said that an
age that's revolutionary and reflecting
and devoid of passion
changes the expression of power into a
dialectical tour de force
he says that it exhausts the inner
actuality of relations in a tension of
reflection
that lets everything remain and yet has
transformed the whole of existence
into an equivocation right
now a little bit later he'll talk about
that again
he brings up character and
here we don't have like too definite of
an idea of what exactly character is so
don't start bringing in
things from other virtue ethics or
anything like that
he says though morality is character
character is something engraved but the
c
has no character nor does sand nor
abstract common sense
either for character is inwardness
there is a when we talk about inwardness
in kierkegaard that means that there is
a
depth to the person and it's not
something that's
immediately evident or obvious
you would have to get to know somebody
in order to know
something about their inwardness it's
not something
that is going to be immediately apparent
from their social media
or their linkedin profile or their cv
or whatever else it is you know reports
that people are having about them
as a matter of fact we might actually
get the opposite of that if you think
about
the way things like instagram and
facebook work where
it's this tiny little you know window
into the person's life
carefully sculpted much of the time
right so he says
character is inwardness as energy
immorality is also
character so character is morality
character as immorality and then he says
it's equivocation to be neither one
nor the other so that's an unusual
use of the term equivocation
usually we use that to talk about terms
like i say
okay go and get me a seal
now do you mean the the pop singer from
who was popular in the 90s with the
scars on his face who's saying
touched by a rose do you mean the animal
that sometimes you know plays horns
uh or or you know we watch nature films
of do you mean like something that you
slam into a piece of wax that's been
heated up to seal it up
or do you mean maybe the seal on a bag
or something like that
that's an equivocation what's going on
here
is an equivocation in a different way
he talks about it being existential
equivocation
when a when the qualitative disjunction
of the qualities is impaired by annoying
reflection you might say well what does
that mean right okay well
so think about uh
character understood as morality
and immorality is goodness and badness
he says that an uprising motivated by
passion is elemental a disintegration
motivated
motivated by equivocation is a quiet but
busy story tastes going on day and night
in argument
the distinction between good and evil
is enervated that means it loses its
energy it loses its firmness
by a loose supercilious theoretical
acquaintance with evil
by an overbearing shrewdness which knows
that the good is not appreciated or
rewarded in the world
and thus it practically becomes
stupidity no one is carried away to
great exploits by the good known as
rush and outrageous sin by evil the one
is just as good as the other
and yet for that very reason there's all
the more to gossip about
four he says ambiguity and equivocation
are titillating and stimulating
and have many more words that are
possessed by joy over the good and the
loathing
of evil we lose track we don't we don't
stop using the terms good and evil
but we get a different sort of mileage
out of it where there's
not a commitment to either one and
there's kind of a blurring
of the distinctions between them or
oscillations
and so you know this is actually a
significant
issue the reflection replaces any sort
of commitment
with ambiguity or equivocation
he also talks about there's a beautiful
phrase the coiled springs of life
relationships
so what are life relationships in in
many of these
there's some sort of hierarchy involved
and
notice that kierkegaard is not endorsing
you know the person on top gets to tell
the person on the bottom what to do
and they should just go along and do it
he talks for example about
you know the loyal citizen who
cheerfully does homage to his king
and now is embittered by his tyranny he
can be embittered by the tyranny
because he did loyal homage because he
acknowledged
that there was some sort of difference
of relation between the two
father and son he talks about as well
he's
he's he talks about uh the father who
indignantly concentrates his fatherly
authority in one single curse
or the son who defies
and then he says this is a rift that
could still perhaps end in the
inwardness of
reconciliation at least when you have
something to push against
you you know where you stand right
this is this is very important so he
talks about
life relationships as involving these
differences
between opposites and those involve
inwardness
these come to be replaced he says
by a kind of mutual watchfulness
he says inwardness is lacking
and to that extent the relation does not
exist or the relation is in inert
cohesion
the negative law is they cannot do with
without each other and they cannot stay
together
right so instead of the relation of
inwardness the opposites do not relate
to each other but stand
as it were and carefully watch each
other in this tension is actually
the termination of the relation he says
this is not the cheerful confident
admiration quick with words of
appreciation that tips its hat to
distinction
and now is shocked by its pride and
arrogance
and so he's got this great example that
i i really love here
uh in part because i can i could relate
to it a bit myself
he says um in education right
in order to think over the relations in
a higher relation but finally the whole
generation becomes
a representation which represents well
there's no saying whom
which thinks over the relation this is
not an insubordinate
adolescent who quivers and shakes before
his schoolmaster
no the relation is rather a certain
uniformity
in mutual exchange between teacher and
pupil
on how a good school should be run
and then kierkegaard says going to
school does not mean
quivering and shaking but neither does
it mean simply and solely learning
but means being more or less interested
in the problem
of education and so you know
he's not saying that this is all a bad
thing it's not like we should say
well students shut up and do what i say
right maybe we do need input from them
you know
but the idea that we totally change the
relation so we're all
on the same level we're all peers to
each other
and we you know spout bs like i learned
just as much for my students
as they do from me i mean if that's the
case you're actually a bad teacher
you haven't been doing teaching long
enough you know or you're a little bit
too
navel gazing about your own teaching
really you should be you know focused on
education
and that does require a bit of telling
people what to do
it doesn't mean you have to beat them or
anything like that right
but these these things are what
kierkegaard calls life relationships and
they're replaced by what he calls
an innervating tension
now what does this lead us to it says
what should such a relation be called
attention
i think but not a tension that strains
every nerve to the point of denouement
but a tension that
enervates life it makes you tired it
exhausts you
it makes it possible for you to engage
in reflection but not
action so he goes down and he's
he's got this example of a grandfather
clock he says i visited a family with a
grandfather clock that was out of order
but the trouble did not show up in a
sudden slackness of the spring or the
breaking of a chain or failure to strike
on the contrary it went on striking but
in a curious abstractly normal but not
nevertheless confusing
way it did not strike 12 strokes at 12
o'clock and then one
at one o'clock but only once at regular
intervals
it went on striking this way all day and
never once gave the hour
and you know for those who don't have
clocks like that because we live in such
a digital age
a grandfather clock like that would
actually
chime when you got to the hour and if it
was two o'clock it would
give you two dings and if it was five
o'clock five dings and a lot of people
had these sorts of things
so this clock just goes off at random
intervals and it always chimes once
it's not much of a clock now is it but
the family still has it
and so he goes on and he says so it so
it is
in an enervating tension the relations
remain
but in a state of abstract non-cessation
that prevents the breakdown there are
some signs that may
be called manifestations of the
relations but the relations are not
only indicated in precisely but
meaningless meaninglessly
so that you preserve the relations but
the relations don't really mean anything
think about if you if you've seen the
movie i think it was mean girls
in which amy poehler presents herself
as the cool mom who's not like the other
moms
that's exactly the sort of thing that
kierkegaard is talking about and you
notice that she doesn't get anything out
of the relationship because of that
nobody takes her seriously they all just
sort of
use her so kierkegaard has other
examples he talks about you know
we want we don't want to abolish the
monarchy but if little by litter
little we could get it transformed into
make-believe we would gr gladly shout
hooray for the king
we don't want to topple eminence but if
simultaneously
we could spread the notion it's all
make-believe we would approve and admire
in the same way we're willing to keep
christian terminology
but privately know that nothing decisive
is to be meant by it none of these
things
really require any commitment or
sacrifice
giving something up on our part
and if the the king decided to act like
a king
then they would in fact remove him from
his kingship
right and establish something new so
kierkegaard goes on and he says that
ultimately the tension of reflection
this tension that we've been talking
about
establishes itself as a principle what
is that principle
envy it becomes the negative unifying
principle
of the age and he says don't jump right
away
into thinking about this in ethical
terms we'll get to that in a minute
but first let's just focus on what's
actually going on
what what is envy and here he provides
us with a bit of
an analysis somewhat metaphorical of
course
he's not like doing straight out
psychology here
but he says that reflections idea
is envy and the envy is two-sided
there's a selfishness
in the individual and then the
selfishness of associates
towards him when you're envious of
somebody else you want to have
what they have and you know if we use
like the ancient greek conception
of it uh you know
aristotle for example talks about envy
as being
pain at somebody else doing well
right and so you you're not happy
because they've got something that that
you have and you would like to have that
that thing
the ancient greeks by the way thought of
the the gods as being envious of human
beings
so that makes for kind of a rough
universe doesn't it
and so there's a selfishness involved in
envy a fundamental
modality of selfishness and it's a
selfishness
that that you would have and then it's a
selfishness
of those who you're associated with who
you think would be like
on your side wanting the best for you
but no they also
are driven by envy as well
and that can poison and pervade anything
else that they
feel to towards you he says reflections
envy and the individual frustrates and
impassioned decision on their part
and if they're on the verge of decision
the reflective opposition of his
associates stops him
so he has in mind not just envy per se
but an envy that limits our
ability to commit to act
to have existential authenticity
it doesn't it wants us to fit in it
wants us to be
manageable and we want that for other
people and other people want that for
ourselves
in an age of reflection
he has this really incredible metaphor
here of a prison
and he says that reflections envy holds
the will
and energy in a kind of captivity right
so there's a
restriction going on there now how does
it how does it work does it like
just hold us in place no because it's
reflection
it'll say there's no point in doing that
thing
you're never going to really amount to
anything
with that just be like the rest of us
and so he says the individual must first
of all break out of the prison
in which his own reflection holds him
first we have to look at how envy is
working within ourselves
and holding us back envy of other people
perhaps also envy of our former selves
of the possibilities that we haven't
realized
what you know i could have been if i'd
written those 10 books
right we have to break out of that
prison and then once we do that
kierkegaard says
we don't stand in the open but in the
vast penitentiary built by the
reflection of
his associates and to this he is again
related through the refl
reflection relation in himself it can
only be broken by
religious inwardness how much however
much he sees through the falseness of
the relation so it's
not just freeing one's own mind
you're still stuck in the whole system
of expectations
and reactions and reflections of other
people that you might continually
internalize
and live out codependency as we talk
about it today would be a
prime example of this sort of thing
right and he goes on and he says this is
a very interesting point of view
it's not tyrants not secret police not
the clergy in the aristocracy
that is doing this to us reflection
does everything in its power to thwart
this discernment
and maintains the flattering notion that
possibilities which reflection offers
are much more magnificent than a paltry
decision than committing ourselves
somewhere
in the form of desire selfish envy
demands too much of the individual
himself and thereby frustrates him it
coddles and spoils him
just as a weak mother's preferential
love coddles and spoils
for his own envy prevents him from
sacrificing himself
the envy of his associates in which the
individual himself participates towards
others
is envious in the negatively critical
sense so
envy holds us back in this
two-sided way now
is is kierkegaard saying envy is always
terrible
always bad no and here he has an
interesting
reflection that he engages in he says
um even the most inspired
age insists on joking enviously about
excellence
that is quite all right if after making
sport of excellence it once again views
excellence with admiration
and is able to regard it as unaltered
otherwise it will have lost more by
joking than the joke was
worth so
and he says even in a less inspired age
if it still has the power to endow envy
with character and is aware of what
expressing it means can have its own
albeit perilous significance and he uses
the example of greeks and ostracism
when you ostracize somebody in the
classic sense
it's not the same thing as shunning
which it's often mistaken for
ostracism was kicking out the people who
you thought were actually
excellent and might become tyrants
so you kick them out and then they get
to come back usually after like 10 years
of exile sometimes they didn't want to
come back
right understandably so
but when you're doing that you're
acknowledging you are in fact
better than me in some respects that's
why we're kicking you out
so so long as there's still a uh
an acknowledgement of excellence and an
existential acknowledgement of
excellence not just a
theoretical or pro-forma one
envy can in fact be not too bad it's not
necessarily good but but it can
you know it can be involved in action
what about ethical envy so here's where
it gets
quite interesting he says that
the more reflection becomes dominant and
develops
indolence the more dangerous envy
becomes why
because it no longer has the character
to come to a self-awareness of its own
significance
it can't really understand what envy is
or why it behaves the way it does
and it engages in this process of envy
i'm going to read this passage you can
think about whether this is something
that
relates to your own experience lacking
that character relates to events
and reinterprets the same thing in all
sorts of ways wants it to be taken as a
joke
when that apparently miscarries wants it
to be taken as an insult if that
miscarries
claims that nothing was meant at all
that it was supposed to be a witticism
if that miscarries
explains it was not to be meant that
either that it was ethical satire which
in fact ought to be some concern to
people
if that miscarries said that it is
nothing anyone should pay attention to
envy turns into the principle of
characterlessness he says
how often have you seen somebody saying
things about people events
groups whatever it happens to be in
which there is some sort of excellence
and you're like oh come on man that's
that's not cool and then they suddenly
change their tune
and they're shifting all the time and
they can't
actually settle on something because you
keep saying
well that's not good either or i don't
like that
they they're embodying what what
kierkegaard here is calling
enviousness so he says that
characterless envy does not understand
excellence
is excellence does not understand that
it is itself a negative acknowledgement
of excellence but wants to degrade it
minimize it until it actually is no
longer excellence
and envy takes as its object not only
the excellence which is but that which
is to
come so envy in this sense
becomes this driving principle
that just wants to pull things down it
doesn't want to build anything up
it's not emulation it's not me seeing
somebody else
write a great treatment of aristotle and
saying man i want to do that myself you
know
or you watching me talking on on video
or
you know in podcasts and saying i could
probably do that let me give a shot at
that no
envy just pulls things down oh that's no
good
you didn't talk about everything you
possibly could have it always finds a
way to do so
it's similar if we move into other
philosophers
to what is also going to be called by
other existentialists like for example
nietzsche resontimont so this
is something that kierkegaard thinks
is absolutely central
in the what he's calling the present age
and you might think about whether
our age is also the present age in this
respect
you